allow any rook checks but it does just
look like one check the king is going to
move i mean it looks like we can have um
a play-off doesn't it now it looks very
likely unless uh anish does something
very silly here um he's just got a he's
played a brilliant game he's attacking
all over the place he's got to put the
ball in the back of the net and we're
going to have well very exciting uh
play-off yeah and uh pregnant
with seconds left on the clock
10 second time is ticking he has to try
to keep the game alive not an easy task
yeah there are so many pieces yeah black
knight's jumping in
black queen is coming with a check
yeah nothing else to do this looks like
a very nice check mate with the two i
mean i hope oh look at that what a
beautiful final position that is one of
them that's actually checkmate we've got
checkmate and look at anisha's face he's
just laughing but look at those two
nights how pretty is that i i you know
we don't see a checkmate like that every
day so we don't see a checkmate every
day
so it's lovely